[Music]
there's only enough moisture in the sand
for the butterflies even though the
rainy season just ended abdullah a
Coulibaly is the mayor of fauna a town
in southern Mali indeed um it wasn't as
dry ten years ago now we can't plant
rice anymore we don't stop chopping down
trees we soon won't have any rain at all
I wrote to say I sent out Tony a few
months ago mayor Coulibaly got a phone
call from the capital Bamako it was an
invitation to take part in a seminar on
climate change one that the mayor was
happy to accept to me for my future
I've been opposed to the destruction of
our forests for a long time but thanks
to the workshop I learned even more
about the consequences of deforestation
it inspired me to do more to protect
nature and the environment
Jambo one more idea together Cesar
Abdullah a Coulibaly is one of around
3,500 officials in Mali who have taken
part in the climate change seminars
these days protecting the environment is
on the agenda of almost every council
meeting
[Music]
most of Ana's 30,000 residents are poor
and subsist on what the land gives them
cotton is the most important crop here
but growing it takes a lot of water the
Niger River is an important lifeline for
Mali and supplies the country with water
year-round but it's too far away for the
farmers in fauna they have to depend on
rain water now that rain has become
scarce many local farmers have begun
selling charcoal Molly's dependence on
wood and charcoal for fuel is a major
contributor to deforestation
faul a funny and his brother madhu are
both farmers and also operate a small
roadside stand mobile villa selling
charcoal for fun we know that climate
change is real what can we do the land
doesn't give us enough to survive on if
we had a choice we'd stop selling
charcoal well my black people but things
may be changing thanks to the new
insights the mayor gained at the
workshop those new ideas have won over
shake Mamadou coulibaly he and his
family run a small farm on just two
hectares of land in recent years their
harvests have been too small
recently shake Mamadou started planting
different crops now his family can make
ends meet without destroying the forest
[Applause]
Maya told us that fewer trees means less
rain that's why I decided to stop making
charcoal and start planting trees i sell
trees from my nursery and grow
eucalyptus trees that i sell for lumber
absolutely he's already sold more than
ten thousand seedlings conservationism
is taking root in fauna ever since the
mayor launched his environmental
campaign
don't have enough you manager what
difference they don't even anoint a man
when I stand here and see this I get the
feeling that were on the right path in
the fight against climate change in
orange a part of that fight is helping
farmers boost their harvests at the
workshop mayor Coulibaly learned about
new drought resistant seeds he knows
that people will move away if they don't
have enough to eat we realized that many
people in the area were selling their
farms and working in the gold mines
because their harvests were too small
that's also a consequence of climate
change Mamadou foam bar also thought
about throwing in the towel and moving
away his harvests had declined thanks to
advice from climate change experts he
bought new millet seeds from Bamako they
only need a single heavy rain to start
growing and that made all the difference
Nabby are used to only harvest one and a
half tonnes of millet per hectare with
the new seeds I get three tonnes the
mayor knows that his work has just begun
he plans to keep raising awareness in
fauna of the need to fight climate
change I hope more people take up the
fight against climate change here then
we'll have lots of trees and plenty of
rain again it's very important so that
the coming generations will be able to
live the way our grandparents did we
used to see wild animals near the town
but now they're gone because the bush
has vanished yeah luckily if climate
change continues life will only become
more difficult for the people here the
desert will keep creeping ever closer
- fauna that's also something mayor
Coulibaly learned at the workshop
you